object-oriented programming is
absolutely the worst thing that's ever
happened to the field of software
engineering
[Music]
in today's video we'll look at some of
the most controversial programming
opinions coming from highly experienced
developers on stack overflow which is
known for its kind friendly and not
toxic at all community i'll give you my
initial reaction based on my 10 years of
experience primarily in web development
but in full disclosure i only have about
5 000 rep on stack overflow so my
opinion doesn't really matter very much
if you're new here like and subscribe
then leave your most controversial
opinion and i'll choose the best one to
win a free t-shirt of your choice and i
just released a whole bunch of new merch
designs so check those out to support
the channel and keep this content coming
alright so let's get back to that
initial opinion that basically says
object-oriented programming is horrible
developers have been hating on oop a lot
in recent years and even the legendary
edgar dykstra is quoted saying
object-oriented programs are offered as
alternatives to correct ones the idea
behind oop has been around since the
1960s and allows developers to
encapsulate data and logic inside of
objects you start with a class which is
like a blueprint that can then create
multiple object instances these classes
can inherit behaviors from each other
forming a hierarchy of abstractions in
addition there are a bunch of design
patterns to go along with it like
singleton factory dependency injection
and so on all these features and design
patterns sound sophisticated and
sometimes they trick you into thinking
you're making productivity gains when
there's likely a much simpler way to get
the job done a common complaint is that
object-oriented languages require a lot
more boilerplate than something that's
more functional in nature and
applications end up having a bunch of
mutable state that's difficult to test
refactor and just reason about
personally i do think these criticisms
are valid but a bit overblown in
javascript i rarely implement my own
classes and basically never use
inheritance instead i create modules
that export functions and plain objects
that makes the code tree shakeable so
that dead code can be eliminated when
it's bundled together you also don't
have to worry about things like
constructors getters and setters that
this keyword which in many cases just
add unnecessary complexity but that
being said i do come across cases where
a class is a really nice way to
encapsulate something and they do work
really well in frameworks like angular
or nest that have put a lot of thought
into how to work with classes in a
predictable way and there's also other
tools out there that i really like that
are fundamentally object oriented like
flutter or the unity framework when done
properly object-oriented programming can
be very nice and intuitive but it may
not always be the best solution so it's
good to keep an open mind about
procedural or functional approaches as
well
programmers who don't code in their
spare time for fun will never become as
good as those that do the idea here is
that if you're not passionate enough
about coding to do it in your spare time
you're never going to reach your full
potential now i actually disagree with
this opinion even though i'm the type of
person that writes code in my free time
i think the reality is that many people
treat programming as a job and there's
absolutely nothing wrong with that there
are some super talented programmers out
there that can get stuff done with a
fraction of the effort that other
programmers might need 10x developers
are real and it's not because they're
programming in their free time they're
just built different than the rest of us
like ellen iverson and his prime didn't
even have to practice and he was still
better than pretty much everybody else
we talking about the game
we talking about practice man being a
programmer is not just about writing
code it's also about communication being
a good team player vision creativity and
a bunch of other soft skills which
brings me to the next opinion lazy
programmers are the best programmers or
another way to translate it is work
smarter not harder i agree with this one
100 but i think a better word for lazy
might be something like clever working
hard is good and all but sometimes it
can blind you to a better solution like
have you ever been stuck debugging
something for hours then you take a 10
minute break and come back and solve it
right away that's a phenomenon
experienced by all developers and has
happened to me many times instead of
working hard be lazy about things take a
break and come back and look at it with
a fresh set of eyes in addition when you
suspect you're doing something
inefficiently it might be valuable to
devote a few hours to learning a new
skill maybe you need to write a function
that checks for an odd number and
currently you have an if else statement
to infinity you might actually save some
time by taking a few minutes to learn
how the modulus operator works but in
some cases learning might even be a
waste of time the next opinion is that
googling it is okay one time my doctor
told me that googling stuff online
doesn't make me a doctor that didn't
make a whole lot of sense to me because
my most important skill as a developer
is being able to google things a better
opinion i found on the same thread goes
like this it's fine if you don't know
but you're fired if you can't even
google it i agree with this opinion
because the daily work of most
developers is about problem solving for
the business as opposed to more
theoretical algorithm implementations
that you face on an interview google is
not the solution to everything but
knowing how to use it efficiently is
definitely a skill that any experienced
developer should have on a related note
another controversial opinion is that a
degree in computer science does make you
a more well-rounded programmer this is
controversial because many influencers
out there today say that you don't need
a degree to be successful as a
programmer you don't need college
learning learn stuff okay
everything is available basically for
free
you can learn anything you want for free
and many big companies have dropped
their degree requirements for developers
altogether personally i don't have a
computer science degree everything i've
learned has been self-taught or learned
on the job and i've met many other
developers making big salaries without a
degree so you definitely don't need a
degree to break into the industry but
that being said if i could go back in
time i would probably pursue a computer
science degree it can definitely fast
track you by getting you internships at
big companies and i do think that
foundation of knowledge would likely
make you a better programmer but on the
other hand is it really worth 4 years of
your time and a hundred thousand dollars
in student debt college definitely isn't
a path for everybody and one of my
favorite things about the tech industry
is that you can be successful without a
degree which is a good segue into the
next opinion there's an awful lot of bad
teaching out there whether you have a
degree or not you'll eventually find
yourself on youtube trying to learn from
one of the many different teachers out
there as a teacher myself and a
supporter of my fellow youtubers i
unfortunately agree with this statement
in fact plenty of people out there
absolutely hate my teaching style
i get mean comments on almost every
video saying the content sucks and that
it's too fast and so on what it really
boils down to is that different people
have different preferences when it comes
to teaching style ironically the biggest
turn off for me is when a teacher has a
highly opinionated take on something
there are people out there who preach
dogma like there's only one right way to
do something that's almost never the
case and my mind is always being blown
with new ways to get things done all the
time the only thing i really know is
that i know nothing speaking of dogma
people have really strong opinions about
unit testing a controversial one is that
unit tests don't need to be written up
front and sometimes not at all unit
testing can be very valuable and there's
even empirical evidence to support that
but also in my experience it can be a
completely useless waste of time
especially in projects where the
requirements aren't very well defined
and likely to change as the project
evolves because if you try to write your
test up front then requirements change
you not only need to refactor your code
but also your tests in addition most
developers don't really like writing
tests in the first place so when you put
a requirement out like 95 code coverage
you get a bunch of pointless tests just
for the sake of testing and horrible
code to go along with it i think quality
is a lot more important than quantity
when it comes to testing or if you have
the resources use a dedicated quality
assurance person or team to validate the
code before it goes out another opinion
that's kind of related to testing is
that the customer is not always right
when building a new piece of software
you generally start with some
requirements from a customer project
manager or some other kind of
stakeholder and it's not like a
blueprint for constructing a building
these requirements are very likely to
change multiple times throughout the
project for non-technical people
software development seems like black
magic and it's very important for you
the developer to communicate when you
recognize something as a bad idea or
something that's going to take a ton of
time to refactor when i first started
doing freelance work i took the approach
that the customer was always right and
ended up working many hours for free
just to make the customer happy and i
really only blame myself because it's my
fault for not being a good enough
communicator but in some cases you may
end up with a very difficult client and
for that reason i generally recommend
people do their billing on an hourly
rate as opposed to a lump sum for an
entire project because it's more
transparent and allows for a clean break
if things go really south what a divorce
divorce i knew we had something in
common yeah sign these and with that
we've reached the final opinion most
comments in code are in fact a
pernicious form of code duplication or
on a related note readability is the
most important aspect of your code for
the most part i agree with these
opinions i think writing code that is
simple and self-describing is the
ultimate goal we should strive for the
reality though is that even if you write
perfectly readable code i might be able
to tell what it's doing but not why it's
there in the first place comments that
explain why something exists tend to be
the most valuable another big question
here is should you write code that is
optimized for readability or performance
in javascript i can write a for each
loop which is nice and readable but it
doesn't perform nearly as well as a
traditional for loop when faced with a
situation like that i start by writing
the most readable code and if
performance does in fact become a
problem then i may optimize it in the
future but ninety percent of the time
it's too insignificant to even matter
i'm going to go ahead and wrap things up
there don't forget to hit the like
button and make sure to leave your own
controversial opinion in the comments
below thanks for watching and i will see
you in the next one